[Music]
I have access to all your photos I can
steal your identity I can become you
this is your place no my mom's that
swell grew up mostly I'm in mcallen
forums and getting into mud in some of
the uses without messing about with
malware
these guys are bragging saying they were
making like 5 grand a week which is crap
I've got me interested it's basically I
was died so I bet you thought this was
gonna look like Sankat mr. robot she's
just a matte book
let's say I'm you and I think I know
what I'm doing
I don't download nothing I don't got no
stupid websites you're sitting there and
it's a week now and you want to watch
your favorite series so you got some
random website click a link and there
you go there's your show nothing and he
wouldn't happens but what you didn't
know is that the website he went on
allows users to submit links and
anything that you just clicked on was
mine so you just let me in when you
click the link you all four as the
download buying telling you what can I
use or where I'll get it
but basically when it goes on your
laptop your stuff becomes my stuff I can
do what I want
can record your screen capture email
addresses bank details I'll access to
all your photos the darkest Facebook
messages I can steal your identity I can
become you know just make up some fake
social media profiles bank accounts I'll
make you saying do things you'd never do
we just got owned so the only thing you
can do is update update and update again
your software and apps they ask you to
update am all the time usually to fix
bugs then also meant to fix weaknesses
which people like me you can use to
attack your device and access all your
private data if you don't update your
software and your apps the weaknesses
they don't get fixed
so you're in a race to update before the
hackers get you people think they're
safe but they just don't have a clue
this is happening countless times every
day on one of the thousands